So we want a new, what we're looking for,
to equal the total amount of money that
Grant can count on getting from his
friends after the second day of sales, so
that needs to account for the money from
the people who bought on the first day and
the money from the people who bought on
the second day. We already know from this
equation that we came up with earlier that
he'll make 36w+22n Dollars from the
initial batch of buyers. So, that means
the equation that we have down here still
needs to have these terms in it. A couple
of the equations don't, so I'm going to
cross them off our list. Neither of these
answers includes the money from the people
bought from Grant on the first day. The
other four answers that are left over All
have 36W and 22N as terms. So that's
great. However this first one only has 36W
plus 22N. It doesn't have any information
having to do with people who bought on the
second day. So that can't be right, since
we know that Grant will make some money
off of that second round of buyers. To
pick between these three remaining
equations we need to go through similar
steps for people who buy wipers and people
who buy nozzles as we did in some of the
earlier quizzes to figure out the terms in
this equation for a old. We know that the
price per wiper is still w. And since 51
more people are going to buy wipers we're
going to need to add 51w in. In our
equation. This choice doesn't have 51 w.
It has 50 w. So it can't be right. Then
for the money he'll earn from these 25
extra people buying two nozzles each is
going to be = 25 * 2 n. Since n is the
price per nozzle and they each buy two. If
we simplify 25 * 2 n we actually get 50n.
So we also need to have 50n, in our
answer. Both of these last 2 choices have
36w, and 22n in them, and they also have
51w and 50n, so that means they are both
correct. The only difference between them,
is the order that the terms are arranged
in. This is just another case, of the
communative property of addition. Awesome
job! I know this was a really tough quiz
so great job for getting through it.